nous avons le meilleur club du monde au
meilleure décision au monde ce club n'est pas
Cela m'a seulement appris à être un athlète
s'est formé en tant que personne
m'a aidé à grandir
inculquer aux hommes les valeurs qu'il défend
son bouclier
respecter l'engagement de camaraderie
et surtout l'humilité
pour rien je suis fier d'être du vrai
Madrid est fier de faire partie de cette équipe
lié à madrid
[Applaudissements]
à madrid, barcelone, laissez-les continuer
pleurer rien ne se passe
[Musique]
Ouais
Oh
nous vivons toujours avec la pression
nous sommes le grand madrid donc nous sommes
habitué
concourir au plus haut niveau et essayer
gagner chaque match
eh bien c'est notre histoire avec laquelle
ce sens auquel nous sommes habitués
[Musique]
Ouais
Je suis très heureux d'être le plus
cher à l'histoire du football m'a donné
Ça me donne une certaine fierté et bien je vais
essayer de montrer ce
ils lui ont payé l'argent pour être déformé
[Musique]
c'est sûrement un jour important pour moi
comme tout le monde et comme tout le monde arrive
les centralisateurs j'ai un peu d'émotion
plus que lorsque j'ai signé en tant que joueur mais
c'est normal à partir de demain
jusqu'à l'autre chose
[Musique]
je
et bon comme suit
[Musique]
Yo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]